exclusive leaked policy exposes Fox
news's stance on woke ideology so of
course the big story I took across and
gets ousted several reports have said he
got the boot because it was part of the
Dominion settlement but uh Dan you had a
show there huge show so I don't know if
you have any insights into this but I'll
just say outright this is like a big
exclusive where apparently now people
are coming up from Fox News saying
inside the company it is woke it is very
Lefty I think the obvious thing is
you're in New York City you got New York
City laws yeah these laws are pretty
Broad and I'm gonna get into the
heaviness of these laws but I'm curious
your experience at Fox News you know you
go from politics then you're into you
know radio now your personality now
you've got a show on Fox News did you
see any of this woke stuff there
yeah man I mean it was real now here's
the thing I I didn't work in Fox in New
York I had my own studio in Florida and
I got to tell you fox never did me wrong
like we we would fight about a lot of
stuff and I you know I said I was
talking to Megan Kelly about this last
week but it wasn't anything unusual you
wouldn't see on his show I mean it
wasn't like oh don't cover that topic or
did they I said off and like they never
told me what to talk about because I
just would have talked about it anyway I
mean there's a reason my I didn't use a
prompter on a lot of my segments some of
them we did but I would that doesn't
happen at Fox like almost nobody I think
there's one host I I think I don't think
Cavuto uses a prompter but it's for
different reasons but almost nobody it
goes without a prompter matter of fact I
had Jesse on as a guest one day in New
York I sometimes rarely I would do my
show from New York like once or twice a
you know a quarter or something and
Jesse came in and I did this big like
rant and he's looking in a prompter and
it just says like Dan ad-lib and I go on
and he's like dude that out of your head
and he's like well how'd you hit the
mark and stuff I said oh you know it
just I just that's I'm used to a talk
radio like we did our thing so no one
ever told me what to say because I
wouldn't have listened anyway but here's
the thing like Tim brings up a point
because I
it's hard I know it's easy to you know
like pile on and if anybody is a reason
to be angry with everything going on
it's me I was there
you know I'm I'm pissed about what
happened I am I would you know the
relationship there I put a lot of time
into
but he's not wrong I mean forget this
stuff for a second I'll get to that I'm
not trying to avoid it but I'll give you
a perfect example the vaccine thing they
did everything they can with me to make
it easy for people to not get canned
with the Mandate but they were in New
York like they had no they would have
shut the building down I lived that they
did everything they could to make sure
nobody got can like okay you're gonna do
this and you're gonna do remote stuff
all right was it what I like them to
like punch him in the face of New York
and say this is stupid we're not doing
it
yeah but with this this is different I
mean this is kind of like I read the
story looks like like they really went
overboard with this you gotta remember
you got a lot of serious conservatives
there how are they gonna feel say you're
a a female conservative host there which
they have a few you're popping in a
bathroom and a guy walks in How's that
gonna go down there if they thought this
through has Fox News considered maybe
leaving New York
they should they should I mean listen
after the Tucker thing they've got
bigger problems I mean I I don't I'm not
sure a lot a lot of people linked it but
this is a great let me can I read
something it's quick I promise I hear
people read stuff on YouTube but this
was someone gave this up to a Breitbart
and this kind of explains it all they
said uh because this is kind of accurate
they're talking about why me and me and
Tucker weren't resigned and some source
told them this is from a map oil piece
that uh bongino and Carlson once Source
said were considered the two most likely
to say you to management
right here a network Insider said adding
that bongino gave zero and Tucker
gave even less fuss
that's kind of true that's why like I'm
not I'm not I'm not furious at them
because I wasn't the easiest guy to work
with I'm not gonna imagine how did it
end I you were just doing it and then
they fired you no no so the show was
number one I mean demo and overall you
know that's remember you can't get
higher number one like we we were
rocking it man we were pulling in killer
numbers even we were a 10 and a nine at
both spots and they wanted to resign for
about six months and I I don't have an
agent I do my own deals always I don't
need it I like my own stuff so I I was
the one doing all the negotiating there
was never a question they wanted to show
ever and then about I don't know about
two weeks out
but from for the at the end of the
contract was I think April 30th or
whatever I don't remember off the top of
my head but uh about two weeks out I
noticed like the tone changed completely
and I don't know what happened I I at
that point I wanted to re-up for a year
I wanted to re-up for a year and I said
let's just punt this down the road and
let's hurry up for a year and then I
don't know it just seemed like they
weren't interested but you know the
people I would do I was dealing with
there
they were genuine with me like they
never bullshitted me at all no one ever
said to me something that didn't happen
so I can't sit here and say like you
know again it's easy for me to pile on
and I have no reason I don't work there
I'm probably never going to work there
again I may never do a hit again on Fox
but I'm not going to tell anybody fairy
tales that aren't true because that's
like short run click bait stuff but in
the long run it things your credibility
not a Tucker story it's got some angles
to it you know so I don't know if
something happened last minute that post
Dominion where they were like let's just
clean house and get rid of these two I
don't know that but you know if things
did change the last two so here's the
interesting thing about this leaked
policy exposing Fox news's stance on
woke ideology they they they say things
that I think are kind of obvious
considering Fox is based in New York
City that uh you your gender identity is
is protected whether or not it conforms
this is New York city and state law I'm
pretty sure
and I've long talked about how the laws
in New York City opened the door for a
major major problem if anyone actually
chooses to put it to the test
so in the daily signal article they
actually link to the New York City
Commission on human rights definitions
they say gender expression is the
representation of gender as expressed
through one's name pronounced clothing
hairstyle Behavior Voice or similar
characteristics gender expression may or
may not conform to gender stereotypes
norms and expectations in a given
culture or historical period
it actually says that meaning if you put
on a safari costume from the 1800s and
call yourself the colonel with a fake
beard that is quite literally what
they're referring to historical period
you can dress like a pirate they
wouldn't put historical period as
protected unless they expected people to
dress up like colonial era Pirates run a
conservative company out of New York
City you cannot there is no way this you
realize this was the intention of the
left hijacking Corporate America too
right you mention our C and the Dei yes
I call it dye stuff the ESG stuff
because they want you to violate your
own core tenant principles which does
what it obviously alienates you from the
core audience that funds you by the way
my producer gee downstairs watching the
chat he says the chat's convinced you're
on drugs they're not used to the energy
I am not on any professional narcotics
he didn't even have any of our coffee I
didn't even have anything coffee this is
my natural state of being here's what I
want to say about the uh the the law in
New York City though because I I think
we need some strong people at Fox news
if there's anywhere that would be
willing to test the limits of these laws
it's someone who works at Fox News who
understands is going too far if you work
at Fox News you can put on a full wolf
fursuit tell your boss your name is
vulciferon Herald of the winter Mists
and your pronouns are Lord vociferon and
Lord vociferons and if they don't use it
they're in violation of the law now as I
mentioned before I've talked to lawyers
about this in New York who said you'll
be laughed out of the courtroom why
would the law say historical period fine
show up to Fox as an on-air contributor
dressed like a pirate with an eye patch
and go Yar links for having me on the
air Maggie and if they have a problem
with it and tell you you can't go on and
say if you don't let me go on I will
file it I will file a complaint with the
commission on human rights in New York
City for violation of their human rights
law let's see how quickly Fox News bends
over backwards here's what I want to see
will Fox News at that point say we
cannot allow people to show up just like
Pirates or or uh I mean it says anything
caveman you could just look like yeah or
or a Roman uh uh in in a toga and then
go on the air if they bar you from going
on the air they're in violation of the
law now go before a judge and say your
honor this is how I express my gender as
someone who's non-binary and it says in
the law historical period is explicitly
protected no judge is going to laugh you
out there's no other interpretation of
that it all depends on the judge sure
but if the law itself says historical
period now look when I first read this
law back in 2019 I said what would
happen I call I called a bunch of human
rights lawyers in New York I said what
would happen if I went in dressed like a
wolf or something instead I was
vociferon they said they'd still fire
you kick you out and when you go to a
judge they'll say we know what the
intent of the law is and this is not it
and they will laugh you out of the
courtroom and I said if a judge has the
right to laugh at me for the way I dress
why not a man dressed like a woman and
they're like well I mean the purpose of
the law and the intent is and I was like
okay so there could be a judge who just
says no this is different this law
explicitly says historical period
that means if you go before a judge
dressed like a pirate and say it says
historical period this makes me feel the
most comfortable and confident in my
gender why can't I dress up like a busty
female pirate from the 1700s with an eye
patch
and and a fake like Keira Knightley from
uh exactly absolutely or a nudist and if
and if the judge says I reject this
historical period clothing which clearly
Falls in line then the law is basically
meaningless but I'm curious because I'll
tell you this if it were me and I worked
at Fox News and this story came out I
would show up the next day dressed like
a pirate and I would get like legit
Hollywood production quality pirate
costume and I'd be like I am going on
the air dressed like a pirate talking
like this yeah welcome to the news
program and if they had a problem with
it it's a violation of the law is Fox
News at that point going they're gonna
they're gonna be presented with one of
two scenarios destroy your audience
sacrifice your audience for the local
New York City laws or relocate
I you you mentioned the New York City
laws and I I think there's Merit to that
but I do think that the ESG uh
considerations from the investors and
stuff I think that has a significant uh
amount of pressure put on on them as
well so I think the combination of the
two is probably the most but that part
of the story puzzled me the most that
apparently they're they are pitching
their their High HRC scores like a net
positive because conservative Network
that's like a that's a stain on your
network from that but there's but
there's big investors that are like
BlackRock and stuff like that though
these uh these investment firms and
stuff like that that have a significant
effect on the the direction of the
corporation because it opens
opportunities if you play by their rules
so you may it may affect your bottom
line and you may lose like Fox may lose
uh viewers because of this the woke
stuff coming out but the in like
BlackRock and stuff like that say yeah
but I want opportunities in the future
the fox's business model though is is
not whatever everybody thinks it is that
most of their money actually comes from
Carriage fees now advertising is
obviously a good chunk of it too and
they don't want to lose it but the hard
reality is even though they were losing
some money on Tucker's show due to
boycotts and other stuff Fox News was
still generating a good chunk of change
I mean they were not in any danger of
going bankrupt or anything like that
what are Carriage fees Carriage fees are
fees paid to a cable channel to be
carried on on like say Verizon these
Cable packages so because nobody will
get cable without Fox very few people
they get paid a certain amount of money
for each user so the problem Fox is
going to have that's bigger than
boycotts ad boycotts are cord cutters
because if you're getting a carriage fee
of whatever say a dollar a person and
there's a hundred million people with
cable you got 100 million in the can
before you've sold a freaking ad the
problem is the cord cutting is speeding
up that's why when I decided I was going
to do interviews after leaving Fox I've
only done two and they've both been New
Media you guys and Megan Kelly because I
am an average supporter of new meters
this cord cutting picks up shows like
this you have to understand like this is
going to be a dumb box in the future
okay is it they call it a smartphone
it's really a dumb box it's going to be
a transmission vehicle people are going
to want to watch Tim pool Tim pool is
going to be your eight o'clock guy
whatever Temple is your whether you
watch it on this an iPad a computer or a
monitor with Smart TVs is going to be
totally irrelevant the cable box is done
we just bought a house and and the guy
comes over to we needed a cable
traditional cable because I still watch
cable news Max and fox and stuff the guy
goes cable box he goes no we don't even
have those you got to go pick one up
yourself what do you mean you're a cable
guy he was not we don't do that he goes
everybody streams now the guy says he
hasn't hooked up a cable box in days I
said really we're the only ones I felt
like I was from The Flintstones so fox
makes a lot of money from that but
you're you're not wrong like there is
pressure from places like BlackRock that
can buy up a lot and can buy up your
stock but if your brand and your value
added right is hey we're going to be the
conservative Channel then I'm sorry but
you got to do conservative stuff I mean
their opinion part is conservative they
got to leave New York who owns it who
owns Fox I'm looking it's 39 Murdoch
it's only 39 though so who owns the
other 50 all right
someone super chatted and said what if
the historical period was pre-civil war
Southern Belle so if you work at Fox
News show up and say you identify as
your gender is non-binary Antebellum and
where old uh pre-civil War you could be
thrown out of there so they can't do
that this is the problem look if they
want to create these laws yeah all it
takes is someone with the willingness to
be like let's see if like let's let's
we'll play game of chicken is Fox News
look Fox News is perfect for this
because the people who work at MSNBC
like what MSNBC does the people who work
at Fox clearly oppose not all of them
but a lot on the ideology
is Fox going to say we will lose our
audience and go out of business or will
we move so it's like the pressure is on
man if you work there you can make the
difference but I wonder if they made a
commitment ever since Tucker and I you
know uh departed from the network
have they made a commitment to kind of
become like a right a right of Center
Network rather than what they were
thinking that that's where the money is
because you got to remember everyone
who's tried that has failed I could go
through a list of probably four or five
online Outlets it started as explicitly
right conservative right leaning who
decided to play down you know what IJ IJ
remember IJ review was hot man when it
started they were doing these like
nugget videos and Vine like videos they
were hot they're still around but
they're profitable I don't know but they
were blowing up they were doing
right-leaning stuff and then someone I
don't know who pitched them this idea of
hey let's play it down the middle the
problem with playing it down the middle
is you just piss off both sides and you
gotta understand like the politics now
are very manichaean they're just this is
it like the next fight is the end and
the next election is the end whether
that's true or not I hope it isn't
unfortunately people feel that way it's
it's not it's not the middle it's that
it's establishment
if you are someone like Jimmy Dore who's
very clearly a leftist but you are if
you're honest about the news yeah I love
Jimmy exactly I played a clip of him
that's funny on my show on my podcast
today it's hilarious Jimmy Dore will
argue socialist economic points and
you'll be like well Jimmy I think you're
clearly wrong about that and then you'll
come to the issue of Epstein or Clinton
or the banks and you'll completely agree
because he's honest Jimmy doesn't buy
into the religion either right like the
whole religion part the ideology that
goes along with it it's like Jimmy's
straight up about like the actual
material conditions which is more close
to like original Marxism with it with uh
yeah materialism I forget the the um the
phrase of these but he was really
focused on materialism and Jimmy thore
does that he doesn't get into the the
the what basically boils down to like
the the
almost the Theology of the left the
whole the trans stuff and the LGBT stuff
and the the the basically the the making
it like a religious uh you know you know
anything though the fox problem is going
to be too the problem they're going to
have is conservatives right I mean I've
been embedded in this move in a long
time over a decade of my life
conservatives don't like to get toyed
with believe me I see it like
conservatives will they will call out
conservatives over nothing nothing
liberals don't have that problem do you
realize like how dumb Liberals are I'm
sorry they're freaking imbeciles you can
lie to a liberal for five years about a
PP hoax right this it's clearly
like there was no
Five Years Tim five years imagine
wasting so just do a Rachel Maddow
probably does 190 shows a year before
her new contract now she's only working
one day a week so figure 190. she did
190 shows a year for almost five years
on a story that is how are you
watching this like what you just I just
wasted hundreds of hours in my life if
you pulled that as a conservative and
and it happens difficult it's a it's a
freaking cold it happened to me today I
did this interview with uh like I said
Megan Kelly on Friday and this lady she
had stuff drives me crazy on Twitter
like I'll respond to randos over nothing
because I just get pissed off and I got
a really like attitude and I just
do some like random ladies like I heard
Dan bongino and Megan Kelly calling Ron
DeSantis a backbencher I'm done with
these two and they said Trump's tweets
aren't a problem I'm like I answered her
back I'm like did you even watch the
show because I went back and watched the
clip I'm like that's not what I said
yeah I said I supported Trump and we've
got a great bench including Ron DeSantis
that's not calling him a backbencher you
freaking idiot and it's like our people
call our people out over stuff that
didn't even happen and we're so annoyed
like you're not principled and yet the
left you can stick it to them lie to
them make up innumerable stories and
they will never give up they'll tune
into Rachel Maddow tomorrow your podcast
kicks ass yep I follow the numbers like
you do if you got caught lying about a
major thing I've got this skinny on
Governor Andrew Cuomo this is coming
down this explosive story and for five
years it turns out to be it no one
watched him pool again but that's not
what we do we're I mean it makes us
better people and I'm proud to be on the
true side of the movement and I agree
with you it's more anti-establishment
than conservative or left I totally get
that I'm vibing with you on that but if
you did the stuff lefties pull on their
audience you be done man thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time